I will never forget this we're in middle
school it's like 7eventh 8th grade and
the TV show Hunter was on I had this
attractive brunette that drove this
Dodge Chrysler Laser I can't remember
what her name was but she was pretty and
one of our friends Troy just out of
nowhere just goes man I'd like to be her
gynecologist and we all start laughing
you know but like and I think about it
like first of all that's very early
seventh grade to say some [__] like that
and then you start thinking about it
over the years cuz it's made me think
yeah you're not seeing the best of the
you're seeing problems you're seeing
problems issues like [__] you might have
only see once problem [__] is what
you're seeing problematic [__] yeah
yeah and you're all up in them too
you're you're fixing it